hey guys i'm ryan right hi I'm shelina
my Sosh Lina and I we were watching this
video called are you might Thai chili
know what happened I was driving on the
freeway and I saw in someone's car my
daughter needs a kidney type O blood if
you could help Jennifer kidney @
gmail.com and I really wanted to help
but instantly all I could think about
since then is how we could help and we
just researched it and we looked online
we found this video I know I don't have
blood type O but if anyone out there can
help out and feel they could do
something to help Jenna live her life
she's a wonderful 26 year old girl and
she's an artist and she loves to write
stories we want to help so we could help
in any way please blue blue it resonates
to me because my dad he passed away a
couple years ago due to kidney failure
you know it's something that does need
awareness and this video's I gotta get
seen by a lot of people but I thought
you should still be out there and in
some way so that way you know hopefully
you guys can help contribute in any way
if it's not your actual kidney you know
you could come out donating so they
share this video people are going
through struggles like this and they
need help we could make such a
difference yeah and I need to increase
my reputation so try to do something
nice
you always know that your mom cares
about you but for something like this
you realize just how committed she is to
my health and my well-being and I'm very
grateful to her that I think the purpose
of doing this film for me is I'm hoping
that Jenna finds a living donor I'm
hoping someone comes forward but also I
hope people learn something about about
all the people who are waiting you know
there's so many people I'm sorry there's
so many people who need a transplant and
I just hope this brings awareness to
that when someone is approved for a
kidney transplant they're listed with
the United Network for Organ Sharing
every time there's a deceased donor
their blood information is put into this
computer and they run a match to see if
anybody in the United States is a match
if it's a perfect match the kidney will
get sent to wherever they live but
typically kidneys are distributed
locally it's a long list it's 90,000
people now waiting for a kidney
transplant and in Los Angeles a 10-year
wait Jenna's blood type is o and O is
the universal donor unfortunately not
the universal recipient she can only get
a kidney from o donor
Jenna's a fascinating person she has
many interests but she's an artist she's
got a great eye for drawing and she
creates characters I love to see what
she does she has a drawing pad that has
actually hooked up to the computer and
it's fun to watch her draw and she also
writes she enjoys writing stories and so
I think she's very talented and I'd like
you know to see her branch out more but
right now her life is on pause and she
is a little in limbo I think a little
history about our daughter she was 14
years old when she was diagnosed with
kidney disease and she had a rare
neurological problem that caused her
kidneys to fail is connected to her
bladder she ended up having to start
dialysis when she was 18 years old in my
three years of dialysis I probably got
about 500 treatments over 1500 hours and
it was very harvey was three times a
week for three hours and it was just
very draining I had no energy and being
so young at the time I was probably the
youngest of anyone at the dialysis
center and that was very hard for me I
felt kind of lonely like I couldn't talk
to anybody about it you know I felt like
nobody at school would understand what I
was going through dialysis is a
wonderful bridge to transplant but I
think ultimately for her transplant was
the best thing one day a woman came
online and read about Jenna's story
which I had posted online and she
offered to be tested for Jenna and it
turned out to be a wonderful thing she
they called me about a month later and
said she was a match and they wanted to
schedule a date with her Jenna's first
transplant was success it was wonderful
she felt better she was able to do a lot
of things she hadn't done before the
problem is when you don't have a perfect
match your body is always trying to
reject and she's had that kidney for
five and a half years and it's been
great and it's still working a little
bit but she's going to need dialysis or
transplant
welcome to the san diego comic-con every
year thousands people come to San Diego
to buy comics and flexible Lucy dance
see celebrities and it's a lot of fun
and it's really good time she seems like
she handles it so well much better than
me I feel like I'm emotional all over
the place and she's she says whenever I
start crying she goes there with the
waterworks oh she's much more stoic
about it but I think you know she's she
knows what she's facing she's been down
this road before but i think you know
she's she's very in touch with it but
doesn't talk about it a lot it's hard
for her when I found out I couldn't
donate to Jenna and she received a
kidney from a generous stranger I
realized that I could donate my time to
helping other people and so for years
I've been an administrator for I hate
dialysis and also for living donors
online and I talked to a lot of people
who are just finding out that they have
kidney disease they're just discovering
that their brothers sister doesn't match
them as a donor and there are a lot of
people who who don't have a mom like me
to to advocate for them and you know
ours is just one story out of thousands
of people who are waiting hoping to get
a kidney transplant once I found out my
friend was ill and needed a transplant
it almost I thought about organ donation
any number of times before and there
were a number of his friends that all
just said let's go get tested and there
were a number of friends who tried and
weren't able to be a match I was lucky
enough to be the person that matched him
close enough that I was able to become
one of thousands of living donors out
there
you know I've had kidney disease since
nineteen sixty eight and my transplant
of twenty years started to put her out
and I needed a new one and it was really
difficult to let people know that you
know I was in need of another kidney and
luckily people ask me how can I help and
I said well would you like to be a
potential donor and they gave him the
phone number that the transplant center
and a year and a half later I'm doing
great and I'm so grateful to people
who've donated an organ it made a
difference in my life that you can't
even imagine you know living donation is
not without risks and the transplant
team reviews those thoroughly it's
called informed consent you want the
donor to know everything that they're
facing it's surgery there's anesthesia
of course you know there's risk but in
the case of Jenna's donor patrice she
was a triathlete she ran marathons and
did all kinds of races and swimming
she's just amazing but also three months
after she donated to Jenna she ran the
Boston Marathon and she came in on the
top 15% of her age group the goal is not
to take someone's kidney and make them
disabled the idea is to have two healthy
people come out of the surgery is very
safety or the probability of running
into trouble nowadays it's so remote you
know anything can happen with surgery
but but the probability of having any
significant impact on the health of the
older the donor it's pretty pretty
remote so I all comes down to the real
motivation or the person but also the
most amazing thing is people you don't
know each other and all you find people
willing to do just don't I mean we won't
mention names here but just recently one
of my patient with 70-plus you got a
donation from donor or much younger and
the dodo didn't know what I thought it
is very important that you become
informed about the whole process because
it is a major surgical procedure there
are risks that go with it but I knew
those risks and was willing to accept
those risks and I thought that it was a
price I was willing to pay to try and
help my friend
generates awareness for my sister she
has kidney disease and she's in need of
a Canadian donor she already had a
transplant about five years ago and it
started to reject again so we're just
running out this spring of the
information like her blood type of
facebook group Sarah so if you could
just take this and just maybe to
remember yeah just spread the word one
click of a facebook share but we're not
excited okay I don't know what my blood
type is o that's awesome thank you so
much thank you we really need a living
donor the wait time is much too long for
26 year old person to to wait and we've
exhausted our family and friends and
we're looking hoping to reach out to
other donors years ago I posted Jenna's
story online and luckily her donor
patrice found the story and she found us
but things have really changed in those
years and now I've got friends who have
found a kidney donor and other way some
friend Larry through craigslist and my
friend Lori was from a step-sister I
have another friend who found a kidney
from one of her twitter friends she
found a kidney for her mom and these are
all encouraging stories because it's
hard to reach out to your community to
let them know what you need we have
thousands of people that you can reach
through facebook this is what we're
trying to do is is find a donor through
one of these social media avenues
yeah I don't know much about cars but I
do know what looks cool and that car is
super cool left leg and again thank you
so much everyone for coming out and
raise awareness for organ donation
there's just so many people who need the
organ transplant so thank you you know
there's there's information out there
just go looking for it and you know
thank you again so much thank you I've
learned that you can't trust doctors to
do everything for you you really have to
be proactive and find the information
yourself I've learned that there are a
lot of people who get people can be so
generous and caring and just to give a
piece of themselves just so somebody can
have a better life and I've learned that
my mom you know you always know your mom
loves you but I definitely seen it
through her actions the last couple
years how devoted she is to my life and
just might health and well-being and I'm
very grateful for to her for that you
know sometimes people ask me how do you
keep going and it's hard you know it's
it's my daughter it's my baby so I want
her life to be easy I wish she didn't
have to deal with this but she does as
much as we can support her we will we'll
do whatever we can but there's a lot of
hope there's a lot of people who've been
where we are and they come out of it and
um well a kidney transplant is not a
cure it's a treatment it's a damn good
treatment and they feel a lot better and
so that's what keeps me going you know
hope is an essential component of living
with chronic kidney disease and I have
to tell you all the living donors out
there you have provided so much hope to
people who are on dialysis but it's very
important to be proactive with your own
health you have to do everything you can
to get the help you need don't sit back
and wait on somebody to come and do
something for you
attack this be positive and take control
of your own life I truly believe that
there's someone out there that's going
to match her and I it might take a while
but I think it'll happen
you